- Après une journée forte
en émotions, Denis Villeneuve
a foulé le tapis rouge
de la Mostra de Venise
pour présenter "Dune",
première partie.
(acclamations)
Tout a commencé avec
une arrivée en bateau.
Le réalisateur était attendu
par une horde de photographes.
L'acteur principal de son film,
Timothée Chalamet, en a profité
pour prendre un bain de foule.
(brouhaha)
- On déménage de l'air,
je dirais!
- Nerveux?
- Serein. Pas très bien dormi,
mais je suis serein.
- Quelle symbiose vous avez
installé ensemble?
À la conférence de presse,
il a beaucoup été question de
la symbiose entre le réalisateur
et les vedettes de son film.
TIMOTHÉE CHALAMET, acteur,
"Dune"
- Déjà la langue,
on peut plaisanter sur ça,
mais franchement, d'avoir
un tunnel de communication
qui était unique pour nous,
ça me... ça me rassurait.
- Protégerez-vous notre fils?
- Je serais prête à donner
ma vie.
- "Dune" est une méga-production
de près de 200 millions $
et un vieux rêve
de Denis Villeneuve qui,
à l'adolescence, est devenu
obsédé par le livre du même nom
de l'Américain Frank Herbert.
À Venise, il a dit que son rêve
s'est réalisé lors du tournage
de la scène du Gom Jabbar.
DENIS VILLENEUVE
réalisateur, "Dune"
- Son visage s'est littéralement
transformé devant la caméra.
Il y a quelque chose... Il y a
une charge qui est sortie et
je me souviens, à ce moment-là,
je pleurais de joie,
puis je me suis mis à danser
derrière la caméra, parce que
je me disais : ça y est, j'ai
un film. Je me suis pas trompé.
- Lors de cette journée
de première à Venise,
des journalistes du monde entier
ont pu voir "Dune", l'histoire
d'une guerre sans merci entre
les Atréides et les Harkonnen
pour la production
de l'épice gériatrique.
Le film est spectaculaire
avec ses images tournées
en Jordanie et ses effects
spéciaux à couper le souffle.
Le véritable tour de force
du réalisateur est d'avoir
réussi à prendre le meilleur
du livre pour rendre l'histoire
la plus palpipante possible.
- Sincèrement, c'est pas commun
pour moi de dire ça parce que,
en général, je suis dur avec
ce que je fais, mais je dirais
que c'est un film dont je suis
fier. Je dirais pas qu'il est
sans défauts, mais je dirais que
j'ai réussi à mettre à l'écran
des images qui me hantaient
depuis des décennies. Il y a
des moments, en regardant le
film, qui viennent me chercher,
qui m'émeuvent beaucoup.
- Après Venise, "Dune", première
partie, sera présenté dans
les cinémas nord-américains
à compter du 22 octobre.
Les prochaines semaines seront
cruciales pour Denis Villeneuve,
car ses producteurs attendent
les résultats au box-office
avant de financer la deuxième
partie du film.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Venis